on average 100
000 americans are wounded by guns every
year
scientists have developed something that
could prevent
gunshot injuries from happening
bulletproof skin what if you
replaced your skin with this material
what is bulletproof skin made of
what do goats and spiders have to do
with this
and could this be the solution to gun
violence
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if your skin were bulletproof
[Music]
it's no secret that bullets are
incredibly powerful
and dangerous a bullet can move
up to 2500 feet per second
with this speed it can make its way
through walls
metal and of course human skin
so if we wanted to make ourselves
bulletproof
what exactly would we need to do
well let's take a look at the scientists
who made the first
bulletproof piece of skin a dutch
research team
created the skin using spider silk
well sort of since spiders don't produce
a lot of silk
it's incredibly difficult to farm it so
instead these scientists used crispr
technology
to make goats produce spider silk
they spliced the spider silk gene with
goat dna
and when that goat had a baby that goat
was able to produce
milk containing the spider silk proteins
and with that the researchers were able
to produce enough spider silk
which they combined with human cells to
make
bulletproof skin they found that
this piece of skin could stop a bullet
but only if it wasn't traveling at full
speed
it's all thanks to the incredible
strength of the spider silk
this protein is three times stronger
than kevlar
and five times stronger than steel
so although these initial bulletproof
skin tests
didn't stop a bullet at normal speeds
let's
assume that they've improved the
technology and it can stop bullets with
ease
what would happen if it replaced your
regular skin
this bulletproof skin might not feel
much thicker than your regular skin
that's because spider silk is 1 000
times
thinner than a strand of human hair and
when combined with our human cells this
new skin would feel just like your
normal skin
but it would definitely act differently
with bulletproof skin our bodies
wouldn't be able to be penetrated by
firearms if all humans had this kind of
skin
this would prevent thousands if not
millions of deaths worldwide
if this type of skin became a normal
genetic modification
it would most likely be given to the
rich and powerful at first
presidents kings and queens would all
have this type of skin
keeping them safer from assassination
attempts
next on the list would be military and
police officers
with bulletproof skin they'd no longer
need to wear bulletproof armor or
protective equipment this would save
millions of dollars and
it would make them more agile on the
battlefield
injuries and death for soldiers could be
significantly reduced
but that doesn't mean that bulletproof
skin would be
perfect sure your skin would be
impenetrable but
you'd still feel the impact of the
bullet getting hit by a bullet
would at best feel like the hardest
punch you've ever felt
and at worst it could easily break your
bones
so don't go running around thinking
you'd be invincible
[Music]
and with this in mind bulletproof skin
probably wouldn't affect gun violence
either in fact
it might make it worse instead of
shootings
there could be an increase in bomb
attacks
and who's to say that manufacturers
wouldn't just make more powerful guns to
be
more deadly they could develop weapons
powerful enough to penetrate bulletproof
skin making it
completely pointless bulletproof skin
might sound like a great idea but it
wouldn't make much of a difference when
it comes to violence maybe being
a single worldwide country could help us
find peace
well that's a story for another
what if before you go on to your next
hypothetical adventure
i want to show you something we're
really excited about this my friends
is the what if 100 book it's a beautiful
collection of your 100 favorite
scenarios
amazing artworks and additional facts
all in good old beautiful print and
paper
if you're like me and you enjoy an
inspiring read and some
time off the screen all the while
supporting one of your favorite youtube
channels
you might want to consider pre-ordering
this must-have encyclopedia of
imaginations
right now click the link below to learn
more